So I want to continue talking today
about a land use and this special problem
that we face in managing
land use and development,
uh,
in the coastal zone.
Uh,
why the coastal zone?
Well,
for several really important reasons,
one is that it's under
enormous development pressure.
People,
uh,
often want to live in urban areas.
They,
they often want to live
in coastal environments,
but also the coastal zone is
experiencing a increased risk,
uh,
of damage from storms,
sea level rise,
and increased pollution that's
also associated with density.
So I want to talk today about the variety
of strategies that might be used to
control development,
uh,
in the coastal zone.
So,
uh,
this,
I thought I'd start out
with a little cartoon.
Good News.
At the current rate of global warming,
we should be able to just
swim over there and eat them.
And under five years,
so within the world,
640 650 million people
live in the coastal zone,
uh,
that,
are at some risk of,
of a property loss or,
or an injury from intense storms.
And the 10 countries with the largest
number of people living in vulnerable,
low elevation coastal zones include China,
India,
Bangladesh,
Vietnam,
Indonesia,
Japan,
Egypt,
the U S Thailand in the Philippines.
So that the,
the overwhelming majority of people that
live in the coastal zone in the world,
uh,
do not have the capacity to,
to manage,
uh,
the hazards that they face.
And,
uh,
the variety of,
of,
uh,
legal and economic strategies
that might be used to,
to,
uh,
prevent serious damages.
The subject of the lecture.
So the growth of cities in the coastal
zone a is a significant issue to pay
attention to,
so that on average coastal cities are
growing 20% faster than any other cities
in the world.
Uh,
and they have 10 to 15% higher densities
and other cities and other 20 mega
cities in the world.
15,
15 of them are in coastal areas.
Now within the U s we have a,
a statute called the
coastal zone management act.
And the act is administered by the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration,
uh,
and it provides for management
of the nation's coastal zones,
uh,
as well as the resources found there.
Uh,
and it includes the
Great Lakes as well as,
uh,
the,
the sea coast.
And it is designed to balance economic
development and promote economic
development at the same time that it
promotes economic costs or environmental
conservation.
So it has a tension built into the
mission statement of the statute.
Now,
there was great debate within the Nixon
administration about the structure of
the statute and,
and what kind of teeth
would be put into it.
Uh,
should the federal government get
involved in the regulation of land use?
Uh,
the way that,
uh,
the state of New York got involved in the
regulation of private land use and the
Adirondacks.
Uh,
and the,
uh,
there were forces inside the,
the Nixon administration,
a Republican administration,
you recall,
that,
uh,
argued quite extensively that we
needed to protect land areas in the,
in the coastal zone and that,
uh,
the cost of the nation in terms of,
of bearing liability and responsibility
for rebuilding damaged areas,
uh,
was growing and,
it was going to be a potentially
overwhelming so that the
overall objectives are
conflicting and include
the phrase preserve,
protect,
develop,
and where possible to restore or enhance
the resources of the nation's coastal
zone.
We also have a,
uh,
a coincidental,
a statute that's created the
national flood insurance program.
Uh,
but that program is now
essentially bankrupt.
Uh,
so the,
the federal flood insurance program
faces major financial difficulties.
Um,
uh,
particularly as the Gulf coast recovers,
it's essentially bankrupt.
The Federal Emergency Management Agency
officials asked to mate that Hurricane
Katrina and Rita together would result
in flood insurance claims of about $23
billion.
Well,
it turns out that then when
you total up the cost of,
of,
uh,
emergency response,
property a restoration,
uh,
the,
health care requirements
associated with these two storms.
Uh,
it's not $23 billion.
It's in the hundreds
of billions of dollars,
uh,
that the u s government expended.
So,
should coastal property be
ensured by the public sector?
Uh,
what kinds of,
uh,
alternatives might there be?
And,
uh,
the Federal Flood Insurance
Program has encouraged people,
uh,
to build in the coastal areas that are
at risk and it offers them a subsidized,
a low rate of insurance.
Uh,
so that in the event of storm damage,
property damage,
flooding,
uh,
the,
government steps in and basically,
uh,
provides low cost insurance
so people rebuild.
So what are the variety of management
strategies that you might use the,
uh,
the different kinds of legal instruments?
Well,
there are certain questions
that you might address,
you know,
how should we go about protecting
open lands in the coastal area?
Uh,
should they be public?
Should they be private?
Uh,
should we employ land use regulation?
should it be managed by a local
government says it traditionally has been
through much of the 20th century,
a state governments a or should
the federal government step in?
And I'll give you a couple
of examples over the next,
uh,
45 minutes that will show you how the
federal government has stepped in and
applied eminent domain,
uh,
to purchase up open areas and resources
that the government thought were
particularly valuable,
uh,
not just because of their
ecological characteristics,
uh,
but also because they provide
recreational opportunities,
particularly in vicinity of
these population centers.
So insurance,
uh,
whether or not the insurance
programs should be,
uh,
continued,
whether or not the
subsidy should be removed.
Uh,
this is an open question.
How about transferable development rights?
I'll speak about this in a few moments,
but,
uh,
the idea behind transferable
development rights is that you have a,
a,
uh,
source zone,
so that if a zone is set up,
a zoning scheme has set up,
uh,
and one area is more restricted,
to,
uh,
limit development than another area.
Uh,
the restricted area might have some sort
of a scheme where they could transfer a
credit,
uh,
to develop,
to another area or a receiving zones.
So you might think about it as having a,
a sending zone and a in a receiving zone,
uh,
and so that if you are restricted,
you can't build on your property because
you're lying within a flood plain,
you're lying,
uh,
say adjacent to a wetland
or a next to the shoreline,
uh,
then you don't lose your property value.
So that this idea of
transferable development rights,
uh,
does an end run around,
the,
the question about,
uh,
compensation,
so that,
uh,
it avoids the,
the,
uh,
the possibility of,
of litigation,
uh,
based upon the Fifth
Amendment that we described.
I went through on Tuesday.
So,
uh,
thinking about,
you see,
I've repeated insurance
twice here thinking about
the idea of easements so that
the government could go into an area and
buy up some of the development rights,
but,
uh,
not all of it.
So,
so,
uh,
the,
the complete bundle of rights might
be broken up into bits and pieces.
You could also imagine a statute that a
would employ a variety of different tax
schemes.
They might be property tax related so
that property taxes could be elevated in
areas that,
uh,
are especially valuable,
and they might be lower in areas that are
further away from the coast outside of
the,
the hazard zone.
Uh,
and you might think also
about income tax credits.
I mean,
what if you receive an income tax
credit when you purchase property,
uh,
that,
was in a low risk area or in an
area that had lower resource values?
Uh,
and also the,
the idea of payment
for ecosystem services.
Now w w what would that mean?
What our ecosystem services?
Well,
I mean the coastal coastal
zone in its natural condition,
uh,
plays many different valuable roles.
And I'll show you some photos in a,
in a,
in a moment that demonstrate
the flood storage capacity.
Uh,
but also the biological diversity is
often a higher and in coastal areas.
And,
uh,
also,
recreational opportunities.
Uh,
marine fisheries,
the commercial value of coastal
zone is extremely important.
Uh,
nearly 75% of,
of marine fisheries are,
uh,
are,
that are,
are commercially,
uh,
caught,
spend some portion of their life in a
coastal estuaries in a wetlands areas.
Uh,
and,
and many of the coastlines,
uh,
of the United States,
they're,
uh,
ringed by thin bands of sand,
that are known as barrier islands.
And these barriers basically act to,
uh,
to protect,
the inland areas,
uh,
from,
intense storm damage.
So that,
uh,
thinking about,
the variety of,
uh,
protective services and recreational
and commercial opportunities,
uh,
in addition to the property
value opportunities that
most local governments are
looking at.
A,
and why would that be?
While local governments get their
primary source of tax revenue,
uh,
to,
offer all of their services,
uh,
predominantly,
based upon the valuation of property.
So as development increases in any town,
in any municipality,
uh,
it offers increased opportunity for a
local or municipal government to secure
additional taxes.
So payments for ecosystem services.
Now,
what might that be?
Well,
supposing,
uh,
you have,
someone who,
who,
uh,
wants to develop in a,
in a wetland area,
uh,
and you have created a regulation or a
statute that offers specific protection
of wetlands and wetlands are,
are protected in the United States
under the clean water act if they're a
adjacent to a navigable waterway.
Uh,
but many states have also adopted their
own protective a wetland statutes and
make many local governments
have also filed suit.
So these areas that,
uh,
are seasonally wet,
or marshy or parts of estuaries,
they get special legal
attention in the United States.
So now imagine that a,
you decided that you wanted to,
uh,
curtail any future development
in a wetland or in,
uh,
an endangered species habitat,
and or in a,
uh,
in a flood zone.
Well,
basically,
uh,
if somebody wanted to develop there,
you might give them a credit,
uh,
so that they could do that.
Uh,
they,
they may have to pay extra.
Uh,
and that money could go into a bank,
a basically an ecosystem service bank,
and they're now banks that have been
created in the United States and in
different parts of the
world where developers are
developing in sensitive areas
that are allowed to do that,
but they have to pay into this bank.
And then that money is used to,
to,
uh,
restore,
resources that have been degraded,
uh,
perhaps in the same watershed,
perhaps in the same municipality,
uh,
or the,
funds might be used to purchase land,
uh,
to,
to uh,
uh,
offer greater protection.
And the trade is a rarely conducted on a,
on an acre,
per acre or hectare per hectare basis.
Uh,
normally,
uh,
you require the developer
to pay for protection,
uh,
at some multiple of the,
the scale of the original development.
So it might be a,
a one for three or a one for four acre
trade developer gets to develop one acre,
but then he's literally financing
the protection of another area.
So this,
uh,
this form of a credit creation
and a purchase and banking,
it's becoming much more
common around the world.
And if you think about,
uh,
the similarity to this between the cap
and trade idea that we discussed when we
were talking about the clean air act
and the sulfur dioxide provisions,
remember that,
uh,
in the north,
in the Ohio valley and up through
the northeastern United States,
you had,
uh,
this cap put on CO2 emission
allowances for all the power plants.
So,
and that allowed a,
uh,
a trading scheme to evolve so that,
the,
uh,
as the ceiling for total allowable,
so to diminished,
uh,
it made the,
allowances,
a much more valuable so that those that,
uh,
could,
those that,
uh,
admitted the lowest levels of Sot,
received,
uh,
credits that they could then
sell to those industries,
uh,
that wanted to keep polluting.
They didn't want to
invest in the technology,
perhaps a scrubber.
So this idea is,
is,
uh,
you know,
very similar to what's being
discussed with respect to,
to a carbon trading,
but,
but also it has great similarity to
these other concepts about ecosystem
services.
So that a,
it's the underlying requirement is that
there has to be some sort of a legal
threshold,
uh,
that's easily identifiable
and some sort of a trading,
a formula that is set up in
order for these to be functional.
So here's a suite of,
of different kinds of,
uh,
management,
alternatives.
Now as you think about the vulnerability,
uh,
of,
of a property and life in,
in the coastal zone,
I want you to be thinking about it.
Uh,
ecologically.
I want you to think about,
uh,
you know,
what principles,
uh,
of ecology or our understanding of,
of ecosystems and how they're structured
and function and how they change over
time.
What principles should you have in mind
as you're thinking about selection among
these different strategies?
And I think that one of the intellectual
pioneers of this idea of tying the
science of ecology,
uh,
with law that would,
would somehow control
the way that we use land.
Uh,
it was pioneered by Ian Mcharg,
a relatively famous landscape architect
at the University of Pennsylvania,
and a,
the individual that,
uh,
really I,
I give credit to for inspiring me to,
uh,
to do what I do with my life.
Uh,
no,
I want you to think carefully about a
population concentrations in the United
States.
Just swirling the,
uh,
quickly here.
Here's Boston,
Massachusetts,
Providence,
Rhode Island,
New York City.
Uh,
uh,
this is a San Francisco,
so that,
uh,
you know,
think about,
uh,
the,
the density of a property
and population that lives in,
in the coastal zone,
so that,
uh,
if you calculate the proportion
of the u s population,
uh,
that,
that lives in coastal,
it's now over 50% of the US population
that lives in these shaded areas.
And the areas of most rapid growth,
uh,
include the northeastern part of the u
s particularly southern New Hampshire
and,
uh,
Cape Cod,
a also long island,
uh,
but parts of Maryland and a also Florida
and Florida is experiencing just a
continued enormous growth.
25% of the vacation homes in the United
States are now owned and in Florida.
And I'm going to pause here
and I hope that this works.
Uh,
I'm going to pause here to see if I can,
uh,
call up Google earth cause many of you,
perhaps,
uh,
have not been to Florida.
Uh,
but,
uh,
take you over and just a
very quick Google earth,
a cook's tour of the,
uh,
of the coastline
first starting out in
the Miami beach area.
And here as we,
as we zone in,
uh,
you,
you begin to see the
intensity of development,
but you also are looking
at a barrier island.
This is one of those thin
strands of sand in this case,
maybe a quarter to a third of a mile.
And with that,
that,
uh,
in its natural form,
it buffers,
it buffers a,
the energy from waves and storms,
uh,
so that,
that,
uh,
that energy doesn't normally affect the,
the Bayshore,
uh,
over over here.
So that,
that,
uh,
this barrier island wants to
migrate in a landward direction.
So this poses a really interesting
kind of a legal problem.
You know,
if you're managing a,
um,
uh,
the,
the development of,
of an Adirondack a mountain,
you don't have the,
the same,
uh,
ecological dynamic going on as you do
here because this is basically just a big
pile of sand,
uh,
and it's shaped by wind.
It's shaped by,
by waves,
and,
uh,
basically wants to literally
wants to roll over itself,
uh,
in a landward direction.
So if you take a look at,
uh,
say a Cape Hatteras or,
or asset Teague island,
or some of the other national parks,
uh,
that had been established
on these barrier islands,
uh,
you'll actually see them
migrating in a landward direction,
often the,
at a rate of maybe a two to
four to five feet per year,
depending upon storm intensity.
So in,
in a,
in a natural condition,
you would see,
uh,
in the bay you'd see,
a wetlands and it would be a very active,
uh,
nursery for a variety of
commercial marine species,
as I mentioned earlier.
But,
uh,
as you,
as you zone in which you can see here
is that the property values and in urban
areas had just gone so high that the
intensity of development is really quite
remarkable.
So that Miami Beach,
of course,
you have the hotels right on the beach,
uh,
with the,
the Cabanas on the beach.
And as you,
you move further north,
you see that,
uh,
the sandy area was transformed
into a golf course.
And,
uh,
over here,
in the sunset islands area,
uh,
just think about,
what this used to be.
This used to be a salt marsh.
Uh,
and the salt marsh was
basically transformed by
dredging up the wetland areas,
the estuary,
and piling up that a soil and bringing
in concrete and other materials,
uh,
to create,
these remarkable little communities.
So,
uh,
people were able to drive
to these communities and,
uh,
also park their boats there so that
each one of these artificial islands has
created a,
you know,
roughly 75 to a hundred different lots,
uh,
at an average price
selling price in the 1970s,
80s,
and 90s and 90s,
uh,
that was,
approaching a,
uh,
$1 million.
So just to buy the property alone,
uh,
regardless of the cost of building a
wood would cost $1 million so that,
uh,
developers,
we're given the license to basically do
what they wanted on the barrier island.
Uh,
and if you look further north
along the Florida coastline,
uh,
you see that the majority of Florida's
coastline has these barrier islands on
it.
So I was going to take you on a,
a flight over this.
I don't know if any of you have played
with a flight simulator on Google,
but,
uh,
I decided against doing that
in the lecture because I
end up spending more time
underwater with a plane
and then on the surface,
uh,
but here you can see the,
the,
uh,
the barriers,
you know,
variable in intensity,
but Miami Beach,
uh,
is probably the,
the most intensely
developed barrier island,
uh,
in the u s if not the world.
So I'll pause back out of this
and head back to the lecture.
And also the,
uh,
the development in California,
in the southern part of the
state is some of the most rapid,
uh,
that,
that we've seen,
although the recent housing crisis has,
has a slowed that.
Now I want you to think also,
uh,
a bit about a technological
solutions because a,
there,
there are many,
many engineering solutions to,
to protect against a loss of life
and following a very intense storm,
uh,
where tens of thousands of people lost
their life in Great Britain and also the
Netherlands.
Uh,
back in the early 1950s,
a project was initiated,
uh,
called the Delta works.
And the Delta works basically
built a seawalls and dykes,
uh,
that,
those in the Netherlands
are quite famous for and,
uh,
they're very effective.
So here's the,
the largest seawall in the world,
uh,
that,
so that it's triggered,
it closes automatically,
uh,
when,
when the sea level rises up,
uh,
a certain number of feet.
And here's the other themes barrier
designed to protect a London against
flooding from,
from a severe storms as well.
So there are a variety of,
of different technological solutions
that are extraordinarily expensive,
uh,
but given the property value,
that,
uh,
exists and is at risk in the coastal zone,
these are likely to be in our future in,
in,
uh,
in us,
urban areas.
Uh,
and think for a moment
about the hurricane Katrina.
Again,
uh,
the,
the low bound projection
of the cost is roughly,
uh,
cost of loss to the public.
$200 billion.
The high bound is closer to
a half of a trillion dollars.
Uh,
and part of the,
the,
uh,
the loss was associated with the
failure of the US Corps of Engineers to,
uh,
make a decision that would
raise the level of the dike,
uh,
that would be protective for can't
afford category five hurricane.
They decided when they
were choosing among,
uh,
different,
structural design alternatives,
they decided that they would build the
sea wall that would be protective only
for a category three to four storm.
Uh,
the reason being that they
had the authority to make
that decision by balancing
costs versus benefits.
So they reduced everything
to cost versus benefit.
And they basically concluded
that the probability of of a,
a category five,
the worst case scenario
was exceptionally low.
Here's an example of that dyke,
a breaking through and the school
bus on the bottom being flooded over.
Now a different approach,
a different approach to this rather than
using a high tech solutions that are
really expensive,
uh,
was,
was being pursued by the u s
back in the 1960s and seventies,
a legal strategy that evolved in Congress,
uh,
to create a variety of new
national parks that were then,
uh,
called national seashores.
So,
uh,
Cape Cod for example,
was one of the first
national seashores after,
after Cape Hatteras.
And so that you can imagine that
there are these private lands,
uh,
and the government was
trying to figure out,
well,
how can we effect,
in fact,
when we create a new national park in
an area of private land or an area that
may be private land or county lands,
state lands.
So there isn't really a complex
mixture of different public and private
ownership pattern.
Uh,
but,
uh,
no,
no federal presence prior to 1961 to 63.
So the park service was given
the authority by Congress.
This is a John F.
Kennedy,
uh,
who,
who assigned this statute,
um,
and,
uh,
and his family being famous for their,
their home.
And,
uh,
Hyannis on Cape Cod,
very families,
very protective of,
of land use and development on Cape Cod.
Uh,
and,
uh,
conservation groups have long thought
that this was an area worthy of,
of federal protection.
So that the park service,
uh,
was given the money and the authority
by Congress to go in and buy up the land
on,
on Cape Cod are a part
of the land on Cape Cod.
And they decided to do that
in a very interesting way.
They decided to exclude areas
such as the village centers,
uh,
and whereas they would buy up the,
the,
the coastal areas,
uh,
that offered a,
the most,
uh,
recreational opportunity.
But interestingly,
they also had the highest property value
so that they were in a sense the most
controversial,
uh,
so recreational opportunity,
the maintaining the,
the,
uh,
possibility of public access to the beach,
which in New England,
in the eastern part of the u
s is extremely difficult to,
to get to.
So if you try to get to the
beach and coastal communities,
uh,
here in Connecticut,
you often have a hard time getting there
because you've got house after House
after house,
uh,
and you've got fences put up.
So that even though the state of
Connecticut has adopted its own law that
demands public access,
this is no way close to the,
the ethic and culture of public
access that evolved in California,
uh,
as well as in,
in Oregon and in parts of Washington so
that different parts of the country have
these different cultural
predispositions to allow public access.
So,
you know,
one,
one way to think about this
problem is to think about,
you know,
which,
uh,
which private lands does the
park service really want to own?
Uh,
do they really want to buy up somebody's
house or they want to buy up a
commercial,
a shopping center,
or do they want airports in,
inside the park or outside of the parks?
Are there many difficult decisions
that have to be made if you decide that
you're going to use the power of
eminent domain to go in and create a new
national seashore or a new national park.
So this was all occurring by the way,
in an era when climate change concern,
uh,
was pretty much nonexistent
back in the 1960s.
But it actually was quite farsighted in,
in,
uh,
as a,
as a legal strategy that we might learn
lessons from today about how we could
manage other areas in the u s that,
uh,
are,
are relatively undeveloped.
And if you look also at the ecological
characteristics of the coastline here,
uh,
you can see the same kind of barrier spit,
but in the natural form,
uh,
that,
existed down in Miami at
Miami beach before that was,
was,
uh,
intensively developed.
Obviously the,
the density is much,
much lower here than Miami beach,
but it gives you a sense of,
of what,
uh,
an ecosystem like this would look
like in a relatively undisturbed form.
So that the,
the national seashore now extends
all the way to the tip of Cape Cod.
Uh,
up to Provincetown includes about six
communities with the most intensively
developed areas excluded from it.
Now the,
the Cape Cod formula for land protection,
uh,
was curious because it,
it,
it gave the government the power to use
eminent domain to go in and take private
property.
An eminent domain means that they would
be compensated for their value loss.
And it's kind of curious because many
property owners realize that a boy,
you know,
[inaudible] now that people understood
that the park service was buying up
private lands,
uh,
property values were
going through the roof.
So,
you know,
whenever anybody wants to preserve land,
uh,
and they have to buy
up a number of parcels,
then it really pays the,
uh,
the last to hold out because property
value is going to be a highest.
And also these rates,
property value increase were
occurring at about 50% per year.
So many,
many people took the park
service to court and said,
no,
we're not going to give you our land.
Even though compensation
was being offered a,
so what they did was they were playing
a game watching property values increase
knowing that,
uh,
the,
market value that they would be provided
for the property would be decided once
the court,
uh,
had made its final decision.
So eight,
10 years later if they could draw the,
the,
the litigation out over a decade,
uh,
when you have a 50% increase per year
that caused the park service great
anxiety,
uh,
and made them,
increased their offer to settle.
But it was a much more expensive venture.
Uh,
that took a lot more time to accomplish.
The Nature Conservancy is used
a similar kind of strategy,
but rather than going into an area
such as the Virginia coastal reserve,
uh,
rather going into the area in and telling
people we're going to create a new,
a nature conservancy preserve here.
Instead,
they set up a,
a variety,
a large number of,
of,
uh,
separate dummy corporations,
that,
uh,
went in and purchased the
tracks independently so that
nobody really had a sense
that there was one group coming in
and they were basically creating this
collective.
And that whole strategy
was designed to prevent,
uh,
people from delaying from holding
out and trying to secure the benefit,
uh,
that,
the increased property value over time,
uh,
would provide.
So thinking also about,
uh,
the,
the dynamics of this environment and
why it's different than an upland area,
a say in central New York
or Central Connecticut.
Uh,
the energy that,
uh,
is,
is pushing against a,
uh,
a barrier such as,
as,
uh,
Miami beach or acid Teague island.
It's coming predominantly
from two sources.
One is wind and one is waves.
Actually,
the sand shifts around more,
uh,
in response to wind because a
prevailing winds pushed the sand up and,
and,
uh,
the,
the central stabilizing
force of a barrier island,
uh,
is nothing more than,
than a blade of grass and a on Cape Cod.
As just one example.
Um,
the kind of seagrass grass that they have,
uh,
mark the Dune grass they
have that often grows up,
uh,
maybe a meter in height,
but it also sends roots down about a
meter in height so that it can withstand a
lot of overwashed by storm waves.
Uh,
at the same time,
that plays a function of building up
these dunes because it just reduces,
uh,
the,
the wind velocity in the vicinity of the,
of the,
of the grass blades down to a level,
I think I'm recalling it at
17 miles an hour on Cape Cod.
So the,
the grains of sand are blowing across,
uh,
the beach and they hit the,
the sea grass and they settle the Dune.
The Dune,
uh,
then,
builds itself up,
uh,
under natural conditions,
under conditions where
people are trampling,
trampling the sea grass or,
or off road vehicles are trampling
the seagrass or developers or are,
uh,
building on building on the dunes.
You have a much more rapid rate of
Dune laws and increased instability.
Uh,
this house is no longer in place.
This house has fallen in to,
uh,
falling over the cliff in response to
a storm that kept chipping away at the
base of,
of,
of this,
uh,
large dude and many barrier islands
also have a phenomena where they have a
freshwater lens,
uh,
of groundwater that sits on
top of the underlying seawater,
which is,
is denser so that most people on
barrier islands as well as on Cape Cod,
get their water supply from this,
uh,
this,
groundwater lens and that is
extremely vulnerable to contamination.
Uh,
and why would that be?
Because it's just basically a,
a huge sand pile.
So anything that is deposited on the
surface can easily migrate beneath the
surface.
So in,
in,
uh,
Cape Cod,
they've now done a storm
vulnerability analysis,
which they've done throughout the United
States and tried to figure out what the
best response might be.
In some areas,
they,
the park service tried to use riprap,
uh,
which are a big blocks of
stone that they put against,
uh,
the,
the edge between the,
the beach and the sand dunes.
And they found that that
was not a good idea because,
uh,
hurricanes and doe northeasters could
pick up those stones and basically,
uh,
chew right through the,
the barrier island using
the stones that pushes the,
uh,
the way he's pushed the
stones right through the sand.
So many people have started
building their houses on stilts,
uh,
or,
refitting stilts,
uh,
and,
the underlying infrastructure,
uh,
that,
would be more survivable and
many don't also understand that,
uh,
during periods of intense storms,
that these barrier
islands want to basically,
uh,
be cut into segments so that,
they get overwashed.
Uh,
and then as the base behind them fill up,
uh,
the tide goes down and the water shoots
out of the bay and cuts across a,
here's a good example
of a house on Cape Cod,
a that was built on a barrier.
And the,
uh,
the individual,
when he found that his house was
floating in the middle of the bay,
he,
uh,
got his boat out and he went out and
he'd put a chain through his door and his
window,
uh,
and dragged the house
back to the shoreline,
uh,
hired a crane operator to
come in and pick the house up,
put it on a track tractor trailer and
drag it back out and put it back exactly
where it was on the beach,
uh,
in the u s federal government through
the flood insurance program paid for the
entire cost.
So here's another good example of the,
the dynamic character of a barrier where
the sands are literally blowing through
an oak forest up on Cape Cod.
So that,
uh,
naturally,
unnatural condition,
uh,
is,
is a rare condition for a barrier.
And the,
uh,
the estuary that it,
that it harbors in the United States now
because of the intensity of development
and the incentive that people have had to,
to try to make money by investing
in property in this era.
Fire island national seashore,
by the way,
is only about 35 miles
to the south of us here.
Uh,
and it's a pretty good example of portions
of it are good example of a barrier
island.
And in 1963,
two years after the Cape Cod
national seashore was created,
the Fire Island national seashore
and wilderness area was created.
So I bet you didn't know that
you are within 35 miles of,
uh,
a will federally
designated wilderness area.
Now,
if you live in a coastal area,
one way of securing your own protection,
uh,
is to try to capture the sediment,
the sand that's moving
along the coastline.
So people,
you can imagine that,
uh,
this coastline was,
was straight and a,
you imagine that a,
the first property owner
in this case decided,
you know,
my beach is eroding.
I'm going to supposing that
this was the area that he,
he was,
uh,
particularly concerned about,
my beach is eroding.
I'm going to build a jetty that will
actually capture that sand as it's being
pushed along the shoreline,
which he did.
Well,
if you're going to
capture sand in one area,
you're going to create a deficit.
And then the next area,
uh,
so that,
that is the phenomena,
this,
this accretion and deficits,
uh,
effect of building a jetty
explains why you have everybody.
Uh,
basically doing the same thing.
And,
uh,
I was flying over the
Connecticut shoreline,
uh,
last weekend and,
you can see these jetties a side by side.
Uh,
uh,
all along the new haven,
the Milford,
uh,
east haven Brantford shoreline.
Very,
very interesting phenomenon,
but very expensive to maintain,
to build in,
to maintain.
And here's another example of,
of how to,
uh,
capture sand.
Let's see.
A Massachusetts Beach
buggers associations,
beach buggy association that a,
uh,
is planning sprigs of sea grass,
in an effort to uh,
to rebuild the Dune.
And it actually works,
uh,
by,
by planning these springs of grass,
they can,
uh,
cause uh,
a dune system to be become restored,
uh,
within a matter of a couple of years.
So the,
the,
the Cape Cod formula or was
also applied to fire island.
And uh,
one key element of this legal strategy
was that if governments at the local
level did not adopt the zoning
restrictions at the park service,
wanted for those more
developed communities,
then the federal government had the
authority to use domain to go in and just
take over the land.
So it was a,
a carrot and the stick idea.
In a way.
If the local government did not
adopt the standards to protect the,
the ecological values of
these barrier islands,
then the federal government would
go in and use eminent domain.
Interesting kind of combination as far I
don't looking down fire island parts of
it or rather intensely
developed a quarter acre houses,
sometimes 10th of an acre houses.
And a,
the underlying aquifer,
in this case a,
was polluted,
requiring them to drill much deeper wells
and to provide a Cuban community water
supply.
I'm gonna Scoot ahead here.
Another example.
Here's an example,
uh,
of a bunch of fairly expensive houses,
sitting on the shore of fire island.
And because these are
extremely vulnerable to,
to,
uh,
storms,
it's very common for this first
row sitting right on the beach,
uh,
to be wiped out,
to be flooded out.
Uh,
which is kind of interesting because it,
it causes a,
uh,
an instant,
a shift in property value on a barrier
when the first line gets wiped out.
So here's a,
another shot of a,
an area nearby when you can see,
uh,
the,
the former house posed locations
marked out by these boundaries,
uh,
so that all of a sudden
these become short and,
uh,
a crew,
a terrific increase in property value.
Uh,
another example of a
property rights mixed here,
uh,
on fire island is the point of woods
association where the land is owned by a
collective of corporation,
a that then leases out the right to,
to take over one of the
houses in the community.
Uh,
for a specific period of time.
It could be 50 years,
it might be 75 years,
and these lease rights are often
passed on down among family members.
So this has been an effective strategy on,
uh,
in this case to protect the common space,
the open land in,
in the middle,
by the way,
you see also an example here of basically
creating a seawall on the base side,
uh,
that,
would offer protection for the
houses that were built here.
But to do that,
they basically had to dredge out
the material here and dump it on,
on,
uh,
other marshland in order to create this,
this,
um,
developable,
developable property.
Uh,
another example on fire island,
if you look at the little
dot up there at the end,
the fire island lighthouse,
it was funny guy.
I flew right over this,
you know,
the other day,
uh,
the firing of the lighthouse is a,
was built right on the end of this spit.
And you can see back in 1834,
uh,
that it was close to the end,
by a 1909,
uh,
the,
the spit at extended,
uh,
several hundred yards.
Uh,
and today,
uh,
the,
the spit is almost a four,
four and a half miles,
uh,
beyond the,
the lighthouse.
So that not only do these barrier
islands wanna roll toward the mainland,
but they also want to extend themselves
in the same direction of the,
the,
uh,
prevailing flow,
the prevailing currents.
Another couple of examples
of pre and post storm,
uh,
and,
and uh,
uh,
this was a hurricane Rita and uh,
some of these were taken
down on the Texas coast line.
The Padre Island area.
Padre island is an interesting,
uh,
additional example of a national seashore,
so that,
uh,
keep your eye in this case,
on the structure,
which is right about there.
So this is pre storm.
Uh,
and this is post storm.
Another example of high rise buildings.
Uh,
and again,
think about this high rise building
sitting on top of a big sand pile,
uh,
structurally rather unstable pre storm,
and post storm.
And in this case you can
see in the background,
uh,
there's almost no damage
to the properties that are,
are,
are on the,
uh,
Bay side of the barrier.
Another example pre-storm
and post storm
pre-storm and poster.
This case is interesting.
Uh,
here's a shorefront owner,
uh,
who was surprised to find
that he was now a corner lot.
So this is a terrific
example of the way that a,
a barrier can get overwashed.
And then the,
uh,
the title flux causes the,
the water inside the channel
just to saw back and forth.
And this occurred interestingly on,
uh,
Nassa beach in Chatham and Cape Cod.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
one of these,
a little inlets,
uh,
was created by a storm on northeastern
and the sawing action of the tides and
the currents,
uh,
an additional storms caused the inlet to
expand to be more than a mile in width.
And the,
the bay front that a lay behind
it suddenly became ocean front.
Uh,
and the,
the new ocean front owners,
uh,
were really upset because they now
faced increasing risk of storm damage.
So they went to,
uh,
the,
the state of Massachusetts and they
also went to the corps of Engineers and
said,
you know,
you've got to step in and you've
got to offer us protection.
Uh,
is,
were,
were too vulnerable or
properties vulnerable to loss.
And,
uh,
it caused now that they
were no longer a bay front,
but they were ocean front,
uh,
their,
shorefront was eroding away and
their property was being threatened.
And the corps of Engineers and
the state of Massachusetts,
uh,
said,
you know what,
we're sorry.
This is a,
is a natural process,
uh,
that,
we're not going to step in to intervene
so that the u s government has stopped
these seawalls and stop building
these jetties to capture sand,
uh,
to,
to protect private ownerships.
Very interesting,
uh,
outcome that has attracted
a lot of litigation,
uh,
pre-storm in poster form.
So I'm going to have to shoot ahead here.
Let me close by just saying that the,
the,
the central questions
that one would ask about,
the best way to manage
property and the coastal zone,
uh,
include these,
should the land be held in public
ownership or private ownership?
Uh,
if you,
if the land is currently
in private ownership,
how should it be taken
into public ownership?
Uh,
should,
uh,
should the land be,
regulated,
uh,
that's a much cheaper solution than
going up and going in and buying up the
land.
I using the power of eminent domain,
uh,
or purchasing the land
from a willing seller.
Uh,
how should we structure
our insurance programs?
Uh,
how are we going to manage the tension
that exists between the high property
value in the coastal zone?
A that provides the fuel to
developers to want to go in and,
and develop a intensively the
creates this public liability.
Uh,
what is the,
uh,
requirement,
to,
uh,
provide compensation,
when a regulation is being used
to protect one public good?
Are many public goods access
to recreational opportunities?
Uh,
the,
the important nursery characteristic
for commercial fisheries,
the ecological value of,
uh,
of,
an estuary to store flood waters.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
if an estuary is filled up,
then it just means the floodwaters are
going to move someplace else so that
there are clear benefits associated with
regulating development in the coastal
zone.
So that if you set those regulations up,
should you also have to
compensate the private land owner,
uh,
to,
if,
if he claims or she claims that are
their property value has been diminished.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
these are the kind of conflicting and
competing values that exist in the coastal
zone.
Okay.
That's it for today.
Have a great weekend.
Enjoy the weather.